Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
L'ultima cosa da decidere definitivamente
è se lei si trovi in una commedia
o in una tragedia.
Per citare Italo Calvino,
Il senso ultimo a cui rimandano
tutti i racconti ha due facce:
la continuità della vita
e l'inevitabilità della morte.
Tragedia, lei muore;
commedia, si accasa.
Noi non abbiamo, come
il personaggio di questo film,
un narratore esterno che decide
quello che accadrà nelle nostre vite.
E di certo non apparteniamo
ad un determinato stile letterario.
Però mi piace pensare
che c'è una qualche similitudine
tra quello che accade al personaggio
di "Vero come la Finzione"
e quello che succede internamente a noi.
Ovvero, la nostra voce interiore
che continuamente giudica
le nostre azioni
influenzando le nostre scelte
e di conseguenza influenzando
la nostra felicità.
Io vorrei chiedervi di fare
un'esperienza insieme a me:
vorrei chiedervi di girarvi
e presentarvi tra voi.
Avete cinque secondi per farlo
quindi prego, giratevi e presentatevi.
In uno studio realizzato
dalla Brigham Young University in Utah,
è stato dimostrato
che l'isolamento e la solitudine
hanno delle conseguenze
più nocive per la salute
di quanto ce l'abbia l'obesità.
Isolamento e solitudine predicono
una morte prematura sotto i 65 anni,
quindi non pensiate che,
poiché siete giovani,
siete immuni a tali rischi!
Noi, intanto, ci siamo appena presentati
e forse, con un po' di fortuna,
abbiamo appena aumentato
la nostra aspettativa di vita!
Ma voi vi chiederete
cosa c'entra l'isolamento
e cosa c'entra la solitudine
con l'ottimismo,
che è quello di cui io
sono venuta oggi a parlarvi.
Ebbene, questi due sono sintomi
molto noti della depressione,
e la depressione non è altro
che la forma più cronica di pessimismo,
o la più patologica, ovvero
la totale assenza di ottimismo.
E se voi pensate che la depressione
non è un argomento
sul quale puntare l'attenzione,
io vi invito a guardare le statistiche,
che per il 2020,
almeno negli Stati Uniti,
predicono la depressione
come principale causa di morte
dopo le malattie cardiovascolari.
Parliamo di ottimismo.
Cos'è, secondo voi, l'ottimismo?
È una forma di vita,
uno stile di pensiero, un emozione?
Qualcuno si è già posto questa domanda:
fortunatamente l'ha fatto
nell'ambito empirico, scientifico.
Uno dei primi è stato
il professor Lionel Tiger
che nel 1979 ha scritto un libro,
"Optimism: the Biology of Hope"
nel quale ha abbracciato l'ottimismo
dal punto di vista antropologico.
Secondo il professor Tiger,
l'ottimismo è stata una forma
di adattamento biologico
che ha sviluppato l'uomo primitivo
per riuscire a sopravvivere.
Sostanzialmente,
l'uomo tende ad abbandonare
tutte le attività
che sono troppo rischiose.
Invece l'uomo primitivo
ha sempre trovato la forza
per uscire dalle caverne
e procurarsi da mangiare.
Una delle ipotesi riguarda
il rilascio di endorfine,
le sue proprietà benefiche dal punto
di vista euforico e anche analgesico.
Diciamo che forse l'uomo delle caverne
è stato uno dei primi amanti
degli sport estremi!
Ma studi più recenti
- e qui si va al 1990 -
hanno introdotto l'ottimismo
come qualità appresa,
o come frutto dell'esperienza.
Il professore Martin Seligman,
dell'Università della Pennsylvania,
ha introdotto per la prima volta
il concetto di stile esplicativo.
Lo stile esplicativo non è altro
che le motivazioni che diamo
continuamente a tutto ciò che ci accade,
che sia di carattere positivo
o che siano delle avversità.
Questo stile esplicativo
può essere ottimista, pessimista,
temporaneo o permanente.
E a seconda di qual è
il nostro stile esplicativo,
influenziamo continuamente
il nostro successo,
in tutti gli ambiti.
Dal lavoro, alla salute,
dalla politica alla religione,
e anche nelle situazioni di massa,
come nello sport.
Parliamo per un attimo della salute.
Lo stile esplicativo ottimista
ha un'influenza sulla salute
che è notevole, ed è in tre modi.
In primis, le persone ottimiste
hanno le difese immunitarie più attive,
e perciò rimangono in migliore salute.
In più, le persone ottimiste
godono di un'autostima più elevata,
e quindi questo li porta
a prendersi più cura di sé.
E anche godono di un
supporto sociale migliore,
perché tendono a sviluppare dei rapporti
di amicizia e di amore più duraturi,
e questo è stato provato che ha
un'influenza notevole sulla salute.
E cosa si può dire sul mondo del lavoro?
Gli ottimisti
- e qua citiamo il professor Snyder,
dell'Università di Kansas -
hanno una componente proattiva
che è indispensabile
nel successo lavorativo,
e si parla della pianificazione.
Gli ottimisti tendono a cercare
delle evidenze tangibili
nel mondo circostante,
per poter supportare
la propria posizione ottimista
davanti alla vita.
E in più, sono persone più perseveranti.
E voi lo sapete meglio di me:
quando si intraprende
un progetto, si ha un'idea.
L'entusiasmo è fondamentale, all'inizio;
ma è la perseveranza
che diventerà cruciale nel tempo.
Quindi a questo punto
ci possiamo chiedere:
c'è una relazione diretta
tra l'ottimismo e la felicità?
Sono le persone più ottimiste ad essere
di conseguenza più felici
perché sviluppano dei rapporti
interpersonali migliori,
hanno una miglior salute
e più successo al lavoro?
O è il contrario:
persone che per varie circostanze
sono già più felici
diventano ottimisti
e lo rimangono nel tempo?
Sulla felicità si sa che un bel 50%
dipende dalla nostra condizione genetica
- e qua, sfido tutti, possiamo fare
ben poco oltre che accettarci.
Ma un altro 40 e 10% dipende
dalle nostre circostanze
e dai nostri pensieri.
La domanda è, riusciamo ad influenzare
questa seconda metà?
La risposta ce l'ha già data
facebook, nel 2012.
Facebook ha analizzato uno studio
su 700.000 utenti,
e l'ha fatto senza il loro consenso
- ma qui non siamo venuti
a fare polemica.
E in questo studio ha segmentato
i contenuti esplicati all'interno
del newsfeed degli utenti
in maniera positiva o negativa.
Si volva provare se questa segmentazione
potesse influenzare il loro stato d'animo.
E la risposta è stata esattamente quella:
gli utenti sottoposti a stimoli negativi
hanno iniziato a loro volta
a postare contenuti di tono negativo,
e viceversa.
Davanti a questi fatti,
ovvero che l'ottimismo
sia così indispensabile per lo sviluppo,
per il successo, per la felicità,
e che lo si riesca ad indurre,
e ad influenzare,
io insieme a un gruppo di ragazzi
abbiamo avuto un sogno
e nel 2014 abbiamo iniziato
a pensare di creare
uno spazio virtuale segmentato
di notizie positive.
Notizie che potevano arrivare
sia dall'aggregazione
che da contenuti originali,
creati dagli stessi utenti.
È così è nato Sunscious.
Sunscious è un social network
segmentato in maniera positiva,
che funziona con la geolocalizzazione,
il che ci permette in tempo reale
di vedere qual è il livello
di ottimismo a livello globale,
e che funziona in maniera fruibile.
Però non volevamo fermarci
soltanto alla segmentazione:
volevamo che questo fosse uno spazio
dove si potessero misurare
i comportamenti virtuali
in maniera tale
da generare delle statistiche
con una certa valenza
dal punto di vista socioeconomico,
e che fossero di carattere ottimista.
Ma avevamo una sfida davanti:
non è facile popolare
un nuovo social network,
lo sapete bene.
E in più volevamo combattere l'isolamento
che, come abbiamo sfiorato all'inizio,
è una componente essenziale
per chiudere il cerchio.
Così abbiamo ideato un'applicazione.
Questa applicazione
è ancora in fase di sviluppo,
è stata presentata in anteprima
a Las Vegas in occasione del CES
e anche accolta positivamente
da una delle agenzie delle Nazioni Unite,
qualche giorno fa a New York.
Questa applicazione è uno spazio virtuale
che in tempo reale,
nel raggio di pochi chilometri,
permette alle persone di interagire
intorno alla risoluzione dei problemi.
Quindi sostanzialmente
io posso postare una richiesta di aiuto,
e far diventare qualcuno che non conosco
il mio eroe spontaneo,
perché questa persona
può aiutarmi in tempo reale.
Questo progetto, come tanti altri,
è solo una delle mille forme
che può acquisire l'ottimismo,
se preso alla base della ricerca
e dell'innovazione.
Ed è, da parte mia
e da parte del mio team,
un invito a tutti voi
a non sottovalutare l'ottimismo
nelle vostre scelte personali
e professionali.
Noi, intanto, all'inizio
di questo speech, ci siamo presentati.
Alcuni di voi magari hanno
una memoria migliore della mia
e ricorderete il nome della persona
che avete conosciuto,
altri magari solo del loro volto.
Ma l'importante è che quella persona
non è più un estraneo.
E i suoi problemi non sono più
così lontani, né così astratti.
E questa, credetemi,
è un'occasione per renderci utili,
per diventare magari
gli eroi degli altri
- e soprattutto è una ragione
per rimanere ottimisti sul futuro.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)